so I'm not gonna go into too much detail
here but before we talk about animating
the virtual Dom it's important to talk
about what's changed about the way that
the virtual Dom is being rendered a lot
of you probably are familiar with react
fiber fiber is a major change to the way
that the reconcile reconciler schedules
updates to the renderer there used to be
no preferences given for different kinds
of updates so when data was scheduled
over things like animation you get these
kind of pauses in jank in your interface
so in fiber animation gets prioritized
over less important things and it's
become a first-class citizen why is this
important well okay I was at the dentist
the other day and I scheduled a meeting
with my dentist before I was supposed to
go talk about speaking at an event the
dentist numbed my mouth and then I went
to the appointment scheduling updates in
the right order ends up being pretty
important if you schedule data before
you schedule things like rendering then
you have these pauses in your interface
and you your your Dom basically has a
like numb face when it's trying to talk
so a lot of you are probably thinking
like why is animation giving so much
priority but the thing is is that
anytime you're interpolating state or
anytime you're changing the way that
something appears in the Dom if you
change the way that that works for
animation it's kind of like a what's
good for what's good for the goose is
good for the gander it means that any
kind of rendering is all of a sudden
much more performant and makes a lot
more sense so a lot of the stuff that
we're covering today it still works in
older versions of react but of course
the later versions of react are you
going to give you the best performance
so I think this quote is great we've
evolved to perform actions that flow
more or less seamlessly we aren't wired
to deal with the fits and starts of
human-computer interaction this is
really true if you think about people
walking into the room right now they
don't just appear before you in space
that would be a little bit freaky
they usually transition into the room
and you know where they came from you
know where they're going that's how
we've evolved we've evolved to think
that's something that just you know
like all of a sudden appears is actually
kind of frightening so you know our
occipital lobe only has these 100
millisecond bursts and if we're building
for the web our minds don't really work
a different way than that that is
actually what our minds prefer is some
sort of transition and interaction so
here's what's particularly exciting
react excels at encapsulating state
that's changing and the whole purpose of
animation is tying those two states
together so by not just toggling States
and instead exposing the moments in
between we build a story that's less
cognitively tasking for our users it's
as if we're telling a story so in
storytelling and in you know something
on the web we have what's called a so
what factor our user attention span is
really short and we have to gather their
attention very quickly we have about two
seconds before it totally drops off
Amazon's discovered that for every one
second delay conversions drop by 7% and
Walmart's found that for every 1% that
it gains 1% revenue increase for every
100 milliseconds of improvement so what
does this have to do with what we're
talking about today well when we're
dealing with animation we're dealing
with perceived performance so how do we
make sure that were them what we're
finding the most clear and useful path
from one place in our app to the others
for our user well one way is to start
with the end if you spend a moment
aligning yourselves with what the end
goal is it's suddenly offers clarity for
what might happen in between so react
brought all of front-end development
into a new age by understanding how to
responsibly deal with state so this is
great because we have a record for
what's changing in our interfaces and as
a user and a human you're constantly
tracking the space around you you're
creating spatial awareness what you're
seeing here are heat maps of an eye on
one web page in particular you can see
that they're not just staying in one
spot they're constantly moving around in
an event called saccade so you do that
because you're a predator and you want
to look over the entire environment see
if something's moving so you can go eat
it you also are prey
you want to go run away from things that
are moving you're doing that to gather
your surroundings and sew things in
motion capture your attention the most
of anything that's the reason why those
ads with those autoplay videos on the
side are really really annoying when
you're trying to read you have to like
disable them like open chrome dev tools
delete you know that kind of thing it
also means that anything that's changing
focus very quickly creates a cognitive
load for us so if the entire team is
aligned from beginning to end you can
smooth out that experience for the user
and without that we really lose an
opportunity the feeling becomes really
jarring and all of a sudden we have to
remap each interactive space as we
understand it it doesn't feel as fluid
it feels more clunky so here's a great
example from code drops we're just
choosing your seat at a movie theater
you'd be able to gain a real
understanding of spatial awareness and
it's really helpful for a user trying to
understand the task if I'm gonna pick a
seat at a movie theater
it's definitely if there's two different
movie theaters to pick from and this one
I can actually see where I'm gonna be
sitting it's definitely gonna be this
site that I go to or this theater that I
go to now I'm biased of course because
I've been working on this project but
part of the reason why I cleared my
schedule to work for workflow as a
client when I was a consultant is
because I think this product is so cool
for react development workflows a place
to manage all your react components it's
a living style guide that gives you a
productive environment for building
components and showing them to designers
and engineers or other engineers and PMS
to get on the same page so we've been
talking about connecting States for the
user and this is shown through this
walkthrough flow it uses animation to
illuminate where everything is in the UI
and some interactions to highlight where
everything lives
the last confirmation screen gives you
this like success so you know that you
have successfully signed up so we get
did a great experiment where they have
these custom loader versus a generic
loader so here we have the kind of
custom loader that you're used to if you
grab just like a loader gift off the
internet you've got this one probably
and they made this custom loader which
she isn't like that crazy or amazing or
anything it's just a little bit of care
and that little bit of care means that
people were willing to wait twice as
long on the site while it was loading
people were willing to wait up to 14
seconds for this one and 22 seconds for
this one so just by showing people that
you care a little bit the perceived
performance is affected and people will
wait for much longer so I made this this
loader for Smashing Magazine I'm not
sure if any of you are familiar with
Smashing Magazine but their checkout
experience when you buy a book and it's
they're smashing cat so they give me
they gave me an SVG which I then
optimized and started animating and SVG
is actually like SVG animation is
actually really really good for this
kind of animation because that entire
SVG and all of the animation involved is
only six kilobytes which is pretty good
if you're going to animate things on the
web it's actually way more performant
than any of those gifts which are
actually megabytes big so one of the
things I really like about SVG is a
format is it's so flexible it's built
with math so we can manipulate it and
make it bounce and snap I made this
animation to honor the yarn release so I
hope I never have to show this slide
again I show this slide every time
because people still think that SVG is
not well supported look at all that
green
we got Opera Mini we never get Opera
Mini right
and this actually goes back to IE 9 and
there's partial support in IE 8 so you
can definitely use SVG and especially if
you don't like positioning things in CSS
because I'm gonna take a super brief
detour here to clarify what scalable
means when we refer to scalable vector
graphics here you can see when we place
the graphic directly in line in the HTML
it has width and height and it
constrains but then if you take those
out the graphic takes up the whole
screen so it will constrain to the
proportions of anything you put it in so
be it grid or flexbox or percentage it
doesn't matter but the innards stay
totally consistent within themselves so
if you don't like positioning crazy
things for responsive in CSS SVG might
be your answer because it stays totally
stable and you can
don't manipulate it okay so now we've
talked about why it's effective to
animate in react let's get into some
nitty-gritty of code details and how you
can actually put this into your site so
when working with an animation we can
start to think about certain aspects of
the way that we build out our components
as the pieces that we'd like to iterate
on or in this case with the sound
visualization I want to alter things
like the timing of the entrance and the
timing of the exit and so on and so
forth so we'll go into more detail about
how we built the animation for this
component a bit later but this is an
important piece of choreography thinking
about things like timing and eases as
things we can easily change in
conjunction with an entrance or exit and
timing is incredibly important timings
put a pivotal for jokes for
introductions this is a really bad dark
UX pattern where as soon as you visit
group on site this modal comes up and
blocks you from doing anything else I'm
just like visiting the site for the
first time I don't know anything about
them and it's like hey like maybe buy me
a drink first if you think I'm being
picky know that google agrees and will
now drop your SEO for any timed
interstitial on mobile so this is
documentary footage of me trying to use
that site someone put a camera on me at
the time I don't know but the funniest
part is we already are used to thinking
about creating beautiful defaults we
already build apps this way with text
and layout we use props this way all the
time but we don't typically do it with
animation we do a lot of reinventing the
wheel when it comes to animation it
makes it much harder for us to put into
production sites so one way that we can
fix this is to create beautiful defaults
for animation and why should we do that
it seems like a lot of work who cares
well it's any it's like any other
technical debt if you do a little bit of
work upfront it's way easier to build
and iterate in a cohesive matte manner
so we can create these defaults for
easing things like entrance exit
entrance emphasis four times when you're
saying like a success or something and
enter an exit emphasis so that you get a
similar kind of feeling across your site
and
never have to remember it again right
like you get these things put into your
codebase and then you know you're
plugging into entrance you know you're
plugging into exit all of your eases say
totally consistent across the entire
site so this really helps on teams that
aren't totally into animation they can
still build out animations they're not
prohibited from doing so and so if you
have stuff like h1 h2 for body you know
an h5 is your typical body copy think
about your timing the same way T 1 T 2 T
3 T 5 is your typical one so you're
already almost there to building out
every animation you plug into HR 2 T 5
every time you plug into entrance and
you've already started if it looks a
little funny and you need it to be
faster or slower you just change it from
T to T 4 or T 3 so creating these
beautiful defaults helps us not just
have to reinvent the animation wheel we
have way less to think about and then we
can decide what kind of animation we're
using rather than adjusting timing and
easing all over the place like we
normally do
so I think about a more common UX
example here let's say we're building
out a card and we can create some
components where we're putting these
pieces together and even adding a
specific animation that a specific
animation component that kind of handles
the entrances and exits for no matter
what's going inside of there
you should have sped up this animation
so I'll show you how I created the
entrance and an exit coordinating react
transition group and green sock a little
further into this talk but you can see
that no matter what's going inside of
there the animation is always going to
be consistent so animating react is
actually a giant landscape because react
has a beautiful and wonderful ecosystem
but we're not gonna get to talk about
all of these things today you know we're
not gonna be able to talk a lot about
you know canvas and react conv and ken
wheeler and guns and beer stank and
things like that we're gonna stick more
towards the dom side of things because
that's kind of your typical use case and
we're gonna talk more about react
transition group and MoDOT j/s and green
sock so let's start with MoDOT j/s it's
one library that I really like working
with and the thing that I like about it
is you don't even have to open up a
graphics editor if you don't want to it
has built ins like bursts and swirls and
you can use them with just one line of
code as you can see here and it comes
with a ton of SVG shapes built in so you
don't even have to be fluent in SVG like
I am in order to build things you can
just hook into all of these shapes and
write them very very declaratively
so I can apply those to those bursts and
swirl animations like I did on my site
for when people you know login or when
people want to contact me and I use a
slew of these shapes too as children of
the burst and within a couple of minutes
I'm able to spin up some pretty fun
feedback on this button so I decided to
create something that's open source that
you can dig into modeis
and react and of course I picked the
thing that's the most useful to you
which is exploding hot dogs so you
should definitely take make good use of
this OSS contribution probably the most
important piece of this whole demo
actually that I should call out to you
is that mode is really performs the best
if you return false on should component
update react motion is a really
beautiful way of animating and react but
it's different from the things that we
looked at earlier because the before we
were looking at things like timing and
react motion doesn't work with the idea
of time it's similar to
game-based animation so it's interrupted
you get this beautiful cascading values
because in staggering animation one
piece is updated from another and in
essence gets it but gets that motion for
free so you're doing these single
movements that are really really
beautiful it's basically this idea of
giving something mass and physics and
sending on its way because of this it's
very very good for these kind of like
native app kind of animations it's not
good for sequential movement where
you're layering one thing on top of
another like a dog going for a walk or
something it's better for something like
a chat head moving around your screen or
something of course we don't only need
to do these huge movements either in
this example we have a layout with small
staggering and animations when we click
on the circles as well as hover effects
for text elements and since we're using
SVG it's so easy to make it scale for
responsive on mobile without any
positioning craziness and in those
circles but we're updating with a click
we're using a staggered motion component
to use the previous styles to update the
next one's placement and in the
component itself which you can see is
actually a staggered motion component
that's how you'd use it we passed an
array of path values giving each path a
key and we update that opacity here's
another example of react motion Network
we're updating many parts of an SVG some
with rotation and some drawing these
letters onto the page but that drawing
the SVG onto the page isn't you know
only something that you can do in react
motion I'm gonna teach you how to do
that right now
so let's say you have a shape and let's
say that that shape is dashed that's
just a path with the dash around it well
you can make that dash really really
long and the dash offset the space
between those shapes is an animatable
property in CSS so you can use any kind
of way to animate this you can use CSS
you can use react motion you can use
green sock you can use
requestanimationframe what-have-you
so I've already console logged the the
length of all of the letters and
200 is the maximum length so here I can
use a ternary to toggle and therefore
draw the length of the shape onto the
page and that's how I created the
animation for Trulia's responsive
navigation we have react motion updating
the stroke around the nav icon on hover
and then on click we transform the other
pieces to make an X and open the nav and
you can see how fluid that motion is
back and forth so I'm not saying you
have to follow what I say but I
experiment a lot with animation
technologies and I play with all of them
so I thought I would just give you my
recommendations for the job so that you
don't have to play with all of them in
order to get going if you don't want to
okay
so let's break some stuff down CSS MJS
or styles or CSS however you style
things it's really really good for small
sequences and simple interactions
because you don't have to load any other
library or anything it's very very cheap
and affordable to do so it's very
declarative way of creating animations
but in order to create sequences that
are a bit more complex um what you end
up having to do is your staggering based
on bate staggering these animations
based on a delay so every time you chain
them you chain another delay which means
if you need to change the timing of
something you have to go update all of
those values which is very imperative so
once you get to three chained animations
once you get to some more complex kind
of movement then I would consider moving
over to green sock and we're gonna talk
a lot about green sock for the end of
this it's really great for sequencing
complex movement and it's really really
good for cross browser consistency and
that's probably the biggest reason that
I use green sock is that if you're
updating a production site I never have
my code all of a sudden break or I never
find some weird use case on mobile or
anything because they're looking out for
you and they're kind of adjusting the
spec for you react motion as you saw is
really beautiful for single movements
you'd like to make look realistic it's
not as good at those chained sequential
in interactions but those single
movements that are based on gesture it
really excels at react tween is similar
to react motion it's
you're using time instead of spring so
you're still using those components that
can be really really nice but if you're
again if you're layering too many of
them then you've got component after
component after component so again if
you get to more than three sequences
that are on top of one another I might
suggest switching over to green sock and
react move is similar to react motion
except it's a little bit more flexible
it's smaller but it doesn't include
things like timing or sequencing you add
that you know based on your needs
snap SVG is not an animation library
people often ask me about that because I
work with SVG a lot it's more like the
jQuery of SVG it has a lot of like Dom
manipulation on SVG and in fact if you
go to their demos page all of their
demos are written in CSS for the
animation because Dimitri Berezovsky
says like that's not really the right
tool for that job and I asked him what
he suggests for animation and he says
green sock so just letting you know that
part web animation API looks great it's
really promising I think it probably is
the future of the web again because you
don't have to load any external
resources but it's still being worked on
which means that even with a polyfill
the polyfill breaks and I wouldn't put
in a production site unless you really
like Pedro duty it's a thing that you're
really into you like being called you
like feeling important when it goes off
velocity react is similar to gzip
without a lot of the bells and whistles
I ran some tests a few years back that
showed that performance was a little
lacking on there but those were two
years old now and I think the web years
are like dog years so that's like 14
years ago now so you should definitely
be running those tests yourself there's
been a lot of work on that library since
since I ran those tests modeis as you
saw spins up shapes declaratively and
it's still in beta but I really love it
I think it's worth playing around with
so one library that again and again
shines when I want to create beautiful
movement and react in its green sock
it's been under development for ten
years and it has a ton of offerings and
I think the real reason that I use it is
it's very tough to find something that
another tool can do that gee sap can't
do but there are plenty of things that
jiseop can do that other tools can't so
let's dig into those for a minute so to
show you some of the capabilities here
we're gonna dig into transforms cross
browser inconsistencies morphing and
sequencing and chaining so many of you
are probably already aware of a just in
case you aren't in terms of animation on
the web not all properties are created
equal opacity and transforms cause the
least amount of repaints you shouldn't
be moving things with margins or
transforms that causes like a lot of
browser jank and things like that so
there are also ways to hardware
accelerate in in CSS or with
requestanimationframe even you use these
properties one is called the null
transform hack which is that z0 on the
translate z backface visibility:hidden
in perspective 1000 I have some
resources and so do the chrome dev teams
if you want to know more about that so
since we have to move things with
transforms it's really important to
address what happens when you work with
transforms well if you work with
transforms a lot what ends up happening
is you want something like this where a
bunch of things are moving all
concurrently together but what ends up
happening is this because there's a
layer for those stacking transforms so
they keep on layering one after another
they wait for each other to finish one
way of working around this is to write
subsequent divs or components all around
each other and then that's kind of messy
and not perfect right another way of
dealing with this is to write out each
single one on each single keyframe step
which means that you're actually like
manually interpolating these states
which is super clunky right like if I
get one of these wrong it looks like it
pauses or go slower or faster in one of
these so what I really like about green
sock is that we write these like this
instead we no longer have to write
transfer sorry
my slides are all over the place that we
no longer have to write transform
translate X transform translate Y
they're all moving in the Dom using
matrix calculations so we're allowed to
manipulate each one separately
now to be clear you can write matrix
calculations with things like react
motion react move any one of those but
writing matrix transforms by hand is not
like my favorite activity maybe it's
yours but it's it's a little bit
complicated and not that intuitive and
the nice thing about working with green
sock too is that it really is happy to
just make numbers move so we can animate
the onion available like you just saw
there with SVG filters because SVG
filters aren't part of the CSS spec
they're not an animal property but all
of a sudden we can make ripples in a
pond move it also solves cross browser
inconsistencies this one's fun SVG Dom
nodes are not even animatable in IE yet
I hope that they are soon Firefox come
on like what they said that they fixed
it and then they didn't it made me cry
so yeah all of these kind of things
really do and add up as soon as you
start animating something if you're
working with green sock it just behaves
the way that it should and it behaves on
all browsers the way that it should and
they correct the spec this is actually
the way that the spec thinks you want
stacked transforms to work that's nuts
that is nuts that's not what I want so
green sock does things like the one on
the left where it kind of corrects for
the spec involvement and makes these
calculations under the hood so that it's
not creating these crazy like kind of
thing it also allows us to do things
like morph SVG which is a really cool
thing where you can pass just one ID to
another from any SVG path value so you
can make them more from one to another
but on top of that they allow you to
pick the index of where it's morphing to
so not only can you animate different
types of path values you can take them
from any index and you can see how
different that movement is based on
where that index is so stuff like that
really makes a difference when you're
working with animation
so we can make things like a fire and a
candle with math on the web and have it
be four kilobytes and we can make smoke
so sequencing and chaining is one of my
favorite parts of green Sox so let's
talk about that before we close up it's
easy to make really really spaghetti
code when you're sequencing and chaining
you end up getting into things like
callback hell or you're you know
creating things with based off of delays
but green sock offers you a timeline
that allows you to just all of a sudden
manipulate all of those which is really
really cool
so when we're working with a timeline
basically Wow my slides are like the
demo gods hate me today okay um we can
stack tweens we can change their
placement in time we can group them into
scenes we can add relative labels
relative labels would be like inserting
into the playhead right here I want a
bunch of things to fire right off of
that event so that if anything changes
before that in the timeline they're
always going to stay together no matter
what happens even if you manipulate
timing I keep talking about manipulating
timing that's because if you're working
with animation that's all you do that's
all animators do we don't do anything
else we're not actually playing with
like making things move across the
screen we're just changing the timing
and changing the easing over and over
again so this is a really really big
deal we can also animate the scenes you
can animate your animations you can
throwing things I'm so excited you can
reuse this theme so you can play them
backwards you can pause them and so you
can create these really beautiful
effects like this one from leo long we
talked about creating a seamless
transition from the beginning to the end
of a user journey and so we'll find the
end of that story and make sure that the
transitions go from one state to another
as seamlessly as possible you can see
some nice morphing of that button from a
circle to a rectangle as well as how the
layout has to move over and a few other
things that really need to be
coordinated in time
and figuring out how to do so you can
take screenshots of your existing site
that you know that first state and the
second state you can create small
storyboards of your existing designs and
find similar enough elements that can
simply be altered instead of completely
changed in order to transition them so
react transition group plus is really
great for working with green sock and
react
remember I mentioned how great green
sock is but I didn't usually I didn't
talk about how I usually pair that with
react well I coordinate entrances and
exits with this thing called to react
transition through plus it's not the
same thing as react transition group
it's similar but what it does is it
offers us these hooks to work with so
here's a comparison of react transition
group and react transition group plus we
have something called transition modes
it's pretty common in an accordion or
navigation or other parts of your our UI
that we're not just making an entrance
and exit but we're coordinating
something leaving and entering at the
same time so we can state without a
bunch writing a bunch of callbacks
whether we want these two actions to
happen simultaneously or if we like one
thing to enter and finish entering and
then the other one to just come in and
this is a really common use case we no
longer have to reinvent the wheel so
these are actually two elements when I'm
clicking on this this is two elements
but it looks like one because by using
those transition modes they can
seamlessly change one of them can
transition out while the other one
transitions in and it looks like one
continuous movement and without those we
kind of lose an opportunity because what
ends up happening is they both fire at
once and one is already done
transitioning when the other one appears
it's not a big one in this case but it
does make a difference in terms of
fluidity so we can encapsulate what's
changing with this thing that I made
that shows page transitions
so in this example I'm using this idea
of screens when we click on the button
we advance the straight screen looping
around and coming back to the first and
each screen we fire a function that
handles our animation separately so in
the in then we hang a timeline off of
that function so we can choreograph and
finely-tuned the way that that movement
works the event was simply our hook and
and one other thing that's really nice
about green sock is it allows us to have
this thing called clear props which
allows us to unset inline styles that
have been placed directly on the element
itself so that if we need to transition
them if we need to move those things in
particular it can take them off right
before it transitions them and so we'll
revisit that first example you can now
guess how he created that animation we
worked with green socks timeline to draw
those pieces of the SVG on and hooked
into the transition component like
component will enter and component will
leave in react transition group plus and
that schedules the timeline calls so
there's tons more things you can do with
it too that I didn't get to cover
there's draggable motion along a path
custom easing physics and throw props
really the sky's the limit
react is awesome at encapsulating the
state that's changing and animation is
really good at bringing those two states
together for the user with those two
things put together we with those things
two things put together we can really
start to make really fluid interfaces
that are beautifully choreographed for
the web I wrote a book that's not this
book this is my friend trolling me I
don't have the man blob animal and my
that's not even my last name this is my
book it's available on O'Reilly from
O'Reilly I also do these web animation
workshops with Val head and where we
came to Paris this year we're probably
going to come back to London next year
if you want to attend those thank you
[Applause]